isabel allende is this week's public
lives feature her new memoir my invented
country explores the best-selling
novelist chilean roots and her life in
america this is an hour thank you very
much
well thank you for coming I was
expecting an empty room it can you hear
me really well so that I don't have to
shout a little louder can we do that
okay who's the person in charge of this
thing okay turn it up a little bit I
hate these phallic microphones you have
two of them here it's just terrible
terrible okay i'm here because i have a
new book coming out called my invented
country it is about Chile Chile is a
long and narrow strip of land that you
probably cannot place in the map it's
down in the southern tip of Africa so to
recent events triggered the writing of
this book one of them was something that
my grandson Alejandro said he saw me
scrutinizing the map of my wrinkles in
the in the mirror and he slapped me in
the back and said don't worry grandma
you're going to live at least three more
years so you know that started me
thinking about where do I belong and
where do I want to live on how do I want
to live those three years that he has so
generously allowed on me and the second
thing that triggered the book was a
question that someone asked in a
conference I was giving the keynote
speech speech and someone from the
audience asked would roll nostalgia
plays in my writing and the question
took my breath because I realized that
all my writing comes as an exercise in
nostalgia in it's not that I'm homesick
but I looked in the dictionary for the
for the for the word nostalgia and
according to the dictionary it is a
bittersweet longing for things persons
or situations of the
past the condition of being homesick and
I realize that most of my writing as i
said before comes from memory from
things that i have experienced from is
it is like a search for roots and many
times in my life I have had to leave
everything behind and start a new in
another place I have been a traveler
because my parents were diplomats then I
was a political refugee and I lived in
exile in Venezuela for a long time and
then now I am an immigrant so from
saying goodbye so many times I think
that my roots have dried up and I have
been forced to plant them not in a
territory anymore but probably in my
books on my memory so in the writing of
the book I have been asking myself where
do I belong do I belong in Chile where I
haven't spent much of my life but we're
all my my background and my tradition
comes from or do I belong in the United
States where I have lived for 16 years
and where my husband my family my books
my friends everything is so in my
invented country I explore that question
and I talk a lot about Chile I realized
that when I talk about a sense of place
it is always chilly I talk about our
defects and our few virtues there are
many and it's a very critical book I
thought that I was going to be lynched
in Chile because of the book but
actually I just came back and it's
number one in the bestseller list and it
has been shamelessly pirated so for
every legal copy that you can buy in a
bookstore three illegal copies are sold
in the street which is very flattering
if you think about it but when i
realized that i was only signing pirated
copies then i got pissed off so i will
as a conclusion of the book after
writing the book i realized that i don't
have to make a choice I belong in both
places and I can have a foot there and a
foot here and I can draw from both
places the best and have my totally by
cultural life fortunately I am married
to a man to agreeing or who thinks that
he speaks Spanish that helps to give you
an idea of the tone of the book i will
read a little bit and then i will ask or
answer questions you can ask and i will
repeat the questions for the ones in the
back and then i will sign everything you
have new books old books other people's
books checkbooks anything but please
only the signature no dedication and i
will repeat this in spanish for the
chili ins in the audience because the
chilean don't listen voy voy a firmar
todo lo que tengan pero por favor sin
dedicatory apar immeuble eaten al dia de
su compleanno etc ok gracias ok here we
go my grandmother Isabelle didn't
believe in witches but I wouldn't be in
the least surprised to learn that she
had attempted to fly on a broomstick
because she spent her life practicing
effects with paranormal phenomena and
trying to communicate with the great
beyond an activity that in her time the
Catholic Church regarded with a
jaundiced eye somehow that good lady
managed to attract mysterious forces
that move the table during her seances
today that table is in my home after
having traveled around the world several
times following my stepfather and his
diplomatic career only to be lost during
the years of Exile my mother recovered
the table through some burst of
inspiration and shipped it to me in
California by a afraid it would have
been cheaper to send an elephant because
we are talking here about a massive
carved wood Spanish table that has a
formidable foot at the center formed of
four ferocious Lions it takes three men
to lift it I don't know what trick my
grandmother performed when she made it
dance around the room by stroking it
lightly with her index finger that lady
convinced her descendants that after her
death she would come to the
whenever she was summoned and I suppose
that she has kept her promise I don't
claim that her ghost or any other is at
my side every day I expect that they
have more important things to do but I
like the idea that she is ready to come
in case of some compelling need that
good woman maintained that we all have
psychic powers but since we don't use
them they actually like muscles and
finally disappear I must clarify that
her paranormal experiments were never
macabre experiences none of the dark
rooms mortuary candelabra an organ music
that we connect with Transylvania
telepathy the ability to move objects
without touching them seeing the future
and communicating with the souls of the
great beyond may happen any hour of the
day and in a very casual manner for
example my grandmother didn't believe in
in telephones which in Chile were a
disaster until the day of the cell phone
and use telepathy instead to send
recipes for apple pie to the three morla
sisters herb awesome friends in the
sisterhood in white who lived on the
other side of the city whether or not
the method worked was never proved
because all four were terrible cooks the
sisterhood was composed of those
eccentric ladies and my grandfather who
was a total non believer but
nevertheless insisted insisted on
accompanying his wife so that he could
protect her in case of spiritual danger
the man was a skeptic by nature and
never was persuaded that the souls of
the Dead moved the table but once his
wife suggested that it might not be the
spirits but extraterrestrials he
embraced the idea enthusiastically
because he considered that more
scientific there is nothing strange in
all this half of Chile is guided by
horoscopes by Sears or by the vague
prognostications of the 18 the other
half hang crystals around their necks or
follow fengshui on the lovelorn advice
programs on TV problems are resolved
with tarot cards the greater part of
former militant lifted leftist
revolutionaries are now dedicated to
spiritual practices there is some
dialectic link between the guerrilla
mentality and esoteric that I can't
quite put my finger on my grandmother's
sessions seem more rational to me that
vows made to Saenz buying indulgences to
guarantee heaven or pilgrimages to the
local holy women I have often heard that
my grandmother moved the Sugar Bowl
without touching it using only her
mental powers I'm not sure where they
whether I witnessed that feat aura from
hearing it so often I've convinced
myself that it is true I don't remember
the Sugar Bowl but it seems to me that
there was a little silver bell topped
with a homosexual Prince that was used
in the dining room to call the servants
between courses I don't know if I dreamt
this episode of or if I have invented it
or if it truly happened I see the little
bell sliding silently across the table
cloth as if the effeminate prince had
taken on a life of his own making a
stunning Olympian turn to the amazement
of the guests and return to my
grandmother's place at the foot of the
table this happens with many events and
anecdotes of my life it seems I have
lived them but when I write them down in
the clear light of logic they seem
unlikely that really doesn't disturb me
however what does it matter if these
events happen or if I imagine them life
after all is dream I did not inherit my
grandmother's powers but she opened my
mind to the mysteries of the world I
accept
than anything is possible she maintained
that there are multiple dimensions of
reality and that it isn't prudent to
trust soul early in reason and in our
limited senses in trying to understand
life other tools of perception exist
such as instinct imagination dreams
emotions intuition she introduced me to
magical realism long before the
so-called boom in Latin American
literature made it fashionable her views
had helped me in my work because I
confront each book with the same
criteria she used to conduct her seances
calling on the spirits softly so they
will tell me their lives literary
characters like my grandmother
separations are fragile beings easily
frightened they must be treated with
care so they feel comfortable in my
pages operations tables that move on
their own miraculous Saints and devils
riding on public buses make
life-and-death more interesting souls in
pain know no borders I have a friend in
Chile who wakes up every night to find
tall skinny visitors from Africa dressed
in tunics and on with spares specters
that only he can see his wife who by the
way is my best friend who sleeps right
beside him has never seen the Africans
she only sees to 18th century English
gentle women who walk through doors and
another friend of mine who lived in a
house in Santiago where lamps
mysteriously crashed to the floor and
chairs overturned the the source of the
main ham was discovered to be the ghost
of a Danish geographer who was dug up in
the patio along with his maps and
notebooks how did that poor wandering
soul end up so far from Denmark we will
never know but the fact is that after
several
novinhas and a few masses for him the
geographer left he must have been a
Calvinist or a Lutheran during his
lifetime and didn't like the papist
rights in Chile one of our
Entertainment's is telling stories the
more macabre the better in that an hour
taste for liquor and poetry will
resemble the Irish we are addicts to
radio and television soaps because the
misadventures of the protagonists offer
us a good excuse to weep for our own
sorrows the lives of the characters of
the TV soap are much more important than
those of our own relatives even though
the plot is not always easily understood
for example the handsome lead seduces a
woman gets her pregnant and then for
revenge marries a girl who is lame and
leaves her to baby waiting as we say in
Chile then he runs off to Italy to join
his first wife I think this is called
trigga me
in the meantime the second girl has her
lame leg operated on goes to the beauty
salon inherence a fortune becomes an
executive in a large corporation and
attracts new suitors when the lead
returns from Italy and sees the rich
female with two legs the same length he
repents of his felony and then begin the
play riders problems in untangling the
mass the first the deuce woman gets an
abortion so there won't be any bastards
running around the TV channel and the
lagless Italian legal wife dies thus the
lead who apparently is the good guy in
the series is widowed this allows the
former lame here owing to marry in white
despite the enormous belly that she's
sporting in time she gives birth to a
baby boy of course in the course of this
tragedy nearly all the actors end up
hospitalized there are births accidents
rapes and drugs teenagers who run away
from home of a prison blind men mad men
rich who become poor and poor who become
rich there's a lot of suffering the day
after a particularly dramatic chapter my
friends call me collect from Santiago to
California to keep me up to date
the only thing that can compete with the
last chapter of a TV series is a visit
from the Pope and that has happened only
once only one time in our history and
with some luck it won't happen again
besides funerals and soaps we are
fascinated with Psychopaths and
murderers we have bad memory for the
crimes of the state but we never forget
the peccadilloes of the man next door
one of the best-known murders in our
history was committed by a senior
barcelo who killed his wife after having
abused her for several years he argued
it had been an accident I was embracing
her he said and my gun misfired he
couldn't explain why he had a loaded
pistol in his hand pointed at her brain
his mother-in-law initiated a crusade to
avenge the unfortunate daughter I don't
blame her I would have done exactly the
same as a result the villain was
executed he was the first and one of the
few upper class prisoners to receive the
death penalty because that punishment
was reserved for those who had no
connections or good lawyers today the
death penalty has been eliminated in
Chile as it has in almost all decent
countries
I grew up like everybody else in chillin
with the family anecdotes how many of
them are true doesn't matter we like
stories at the hour of remembering no
one wants verification of the facts the
legend is enough like the sad tale of
the ghost that during a séance told my
grandmother the location of the treasure
hidden beneath the stairs due to an
error in the plan of the property not
because of any malevolence on the part
of the spirit the treasure was never
found even though they tore down half
the house in Chile it is bad manners to
acknowledge that you are overly
satisfied because that can irritate the
less fortunate that is why for the
correct answer to the question how are
you is so and so this is the opening for
sympathizing with the other speakers
situation for example if one person says
has just been diagnosed with the fatal
illness it would be very bad taste to
rub on his foot in his face how well
everything is going for you wouldn't it
sociologists say that forty percent of
jillians suffer from depression
especially the women who have to put up
with the men you must remember too that
our country goes through major disasters
and that there are many poor so it seems
rude to mention one's own good fortune I
had a relative who twice won the jackpot
in the lottery but he always said so and
so in order not to offend as an aside
it's rather interesting to learn how his
good fortune came about this relative of
mine was a strong Catholic as most of
them are and as such never wanted to
hear talk of contraception after his
seventh child was born desperate he went
to church knelt before the altar and had
a hard
to heart conversation with his creator
Lord since you've sent me seven children
it would be a kindness you help me feed
them he argued and immediately took a
long carefully prepared list of expenses
from his pocket God listened patiently
to his expenses and then revealed to his
loyal servant the winning lottery number
in a dream those millions lasted for
several years but inflation which was an
endemic problem during that time reduced
his capital at the same rate that he
enlarged his family when the last of his
children was born number 11 he returned
to church to argue his case and again
God after hearing the list came to his
aid by sending a second revelation in a
dream the third time it was no deal I
don't want to give you the impression
that we are all bad which he lends have
a few verges let me think about one well
for example we are people with poetic
Souls it isn't our fault I can blame
that one on the landscape no one that is
born and lives in a natural world like
ours can resist writing poetry in Chile
you lift up a rock and instead of a
lizard outgrows a poet or a troubadour
we admire our writers we respect them
and we put up with a neurosis the male
writers I mean not those from any other
known gender I can add about our
character that we are affectionate we go
around bestowing kisses right and left
we greet each other with a sincere kiss
on the right cheek children kiss adults
as they arrive and as they leave and as
an additional sign of respect they call
them uncle or aunt as they do in China
all the people are kissed merciless even
against their will
women kiss even if they hate each other
and they kiss any mail within reach a
neither age nor social class nor hygiene
can dissuade them only males in their
reproductive years let's say between 14
and 80 do not kiss each other but they
heartily embrace our affection has many
other manifestations from opening the
doors to our house to receive anyone who
shows up unexpectedly to sharing
everything we have you should never
praised something another person is
wearing because he or she is certain to
quip it off and give it to you if there
is food left from a meal the genteel
thing to do is to give it to the guests
to take home just as you never arrive at
someone's house with empty hands with
Jillian's have a sense of humor but deep
down we prefer seriousness we had a
president who was a neurotic bachelor
and people said about him with
admiration how sad don't hurt he is that
was reassuring for us we were in good
hands those of an aging depressive who
wasted no time in happiness which is not
to say that we don't find bad luck
entertaining we sharpen our sense of
humor when things go badly and since
they go badly all the time we laugh a
lot my family lacks taste in matters of
humor the only jokes my relatives
understand our German stories about her
Otto with a German accent of course but
if I add the German accent to my Spanish
one you won't understand a word so here
is one example of her Otto stories are
there any jillians in this room la
verdad el cuento didonato here's one a
very elegant lady broke wind and
voluntarily and loudly and to cover up
she made noise with her shoes
then her Otto says you can break a shoe
you can break a heart but you will never
make the noise that you make with that
fast
I love this job I just love it you know
I've tried to tell this joke to my
husband but it doesn't translate and
besides in California ethnic jokes are
not really in favor I grew up with jokes
about Galicians Jews Turks you name them
our humor is black we never let an
opportunity pass to make fun of other
people wherever they may be deaf mutes
the [ __ ] epileptics people of color
homosexual priests the homeless we have
jokes about all religions and all races
the first time I heard the expression
politically correct I was 45 years old I
have never been able to explain what
that means to my relatives in Chile you
know once in California I tried to get
one of those dogs that they trained to
lead the blind but are given away
because they don't pass the rigorous
tests in my application I had the bad
idea of mentioning that I wanted to
reject a dog by return mail i received a
dry note informing me that the term
rejected was never used instead instead
you say that the animal has changed
careers
yeah you try to explain that in Chile
you know my mixed my mixed marriage with
a gringo hasn't gone all that badly we
get along even though most of the time
neither of us knows could the hell the
other one is talking about the greatest
drawback is that we don't share a sense
of humor Willy cannot believe that I'm
really funny in Spanish and as for me I
never know what the devil he's laughing
about the one thing that amuses us both
at the same time is the off the cup
speeches of president george w bush
thank you very much
thank you so now we'll answer your
questions I can hardly see because is
there any room for the yeah that's much
better hola what are you doing here well
this thing to you oh we've come up to
hear you this was terrific I read this
book both in english and in spanish i
want to follow up what you said about
the reaction in chi late because you say
a lot of wonderful things about Chileans
but you're pretty tough on them as well
and I imagine there was a more kind of
critical reaction in Chile than you
alluded to at the beginning could you
elaborate a little bit about that
actually I thought as I said before that
I reaction was going to be brutal
against me but I realized that everybody
was laughing with the book and they
enjoyed it and there were the critics
were pretty good pretty favorable all
the reviews and I I think I understand
why you know in Chile and first of all
we accept criticism as long as it's not
from anybody from abroad from a fro a
foreigner I mean if we are chillin we
can say anything about ourselves and
we're all the time whining and
complaining but if it's somebody else
then we can't say anything bad when I
was young I had a feminist humorous
column in a magazine in which I just
wrote horrible things about men and I
got a lot of fan letters from men who
would say in the letter I have a friend
who is just like that you know it was
always a friend and i think that the
same thing has happened with this book
everybody thinks it's the neighbor yeah
somebody else
yeah hello yeah I like to asking you
about your books or you're in several
books most oblivious fiction why not you
write real is from reddit I'm yes much
realism I don't know but that's you
that's why I I interpret you books I
like to asking you if if it's fiction
you favor occur in the future can you
write a real book really yeah I
understand yeah as a journalist keep you
my phone yeah books book Charlie neural
is so I not a second question is avail
as a as you were expert as writers which
problems number one of its panic or
Latin America community in the United
States number yeah let me let me see if
I can answer those questions the first
one if i'm going to write books that are
nonfiction I i have written a couple of
memoirs that supposedly are not fiction
but they are like fiction how much is
true and how much is not true I think
that if anybody in the audience has to
write their story or tell their story
they choose what to tell what parts they
will highlight with twitch parts they
will emit which tone they will give to a
paragraph there adjectives that you
choose to describe a situation that's
already very subjective and that may
gives you a power a control that we
don't have in real life so in a way
everything is fictionalized when it
comes to writing especially to write the
kind of books I write and I don't think
i will ever even when I was a journalist
I was a lousy journalist I I lied all
the time I I was never objective and if
I didn't have a story I made it up which
is exactly what they which every
journalist almost every journalist us
and regarding the second story that the
number one problem for a writer for a
Hispanic writer in this country is the
fact that most of us write in spanish
and so we don't
we can show our work to almost any
publisher because nobody none of the in
the big publishing houses speak Spanish
or read Spanish so we need agents we
need translators we have to go through a
lot of in between things that most
people who write in English don't need
to do that in my case I'm lucky because
my translator translates my books
without a contract so by the time I
start talking about a contract with the
publisher they can already read the
translation into English oh I think that
our biggest problem is that now
fortunately and this is in the last five
or six years some publishing houses like
pub like HarperCollins published some
books in Spanish all my books are
published simultaneously in English and
Spanish by harpercollins in the United
States but that is unusual and only very
recently yes yes thank you this is a
wonderful presentation a wonderful
experience I remember years ago reading
a review of the house of the spirits
written in the u.s. praising it and in
part praising it as a book that's not
political which to my mind simply meant
not partisan and and to again to my mind
stem from an aversion in the US towards
politics of any kind whether with a
large p or small p and so i just wanted
to hear what I wonder what your reply is
to that kind of analysis thank you I
think that all my books have political
elements because politics have shaped my
life I'm not partisan in the sense that
I but politics affect my life and
everybody else's life when one says I'm
not a political person that's a position
already I said no I don't vote that's
also a position so everything that you
do is is political even by by abstinence
it becomes political and coming from
Latin America it is impossible to ignore
the problems that the society has and
it's impossible to avoid the desire to
change things I felt foreigner in this
country for a very long time and I
thought I would always be a foreigner I
sort of liked it it gave me freedom in a
way to be whatever I wanted
nobody cared but but in the last few
years I have felt more and more that I
belong here and the feeling of belonging
is the desire to change the things I
don't like and the mission to get
involved to change and to and to do good
and to participate and I think that is
for me really important you know a
country like a husband can always be
improved
all I survey Paula I just want to to try
to plant this seed in your heart of
something that I have been observing in
your books and I might not mean by no
means an expert but I sense it with my
intuition and is the fact that you have
been able to portray the feminine soul
in a way that is not putting men into
oblivion but that shows the connection
that we may have with nature and energy
and I will never forget that paragraph
in your dos palabras your story when you
show how release a caboose cool area
felt in front of this general so i
invite you to think and see if you might
create another fiction thing that as you
say a country can be changed a husband
can also be changed but maybe they
should be changed and the way of our
liberation movement can also be change
thank you thank you
thank you for sharing your spirit with
us tonight thank you it's quite
infectious I wanted to ask you at the
end of this book well well based on the
premise that a writer writes for herself
and strangers and a writer also begins
that next book in an attempt to discover
things that may not already been be
known i'm wondering therefore what your
largest discoveries out of this most
recent book might have been and if how
you how completing this book having
finished it you might answer your your
grandson alejandro is it about those
three years how you might choose to
spend them yeah well I do hope that my
grandson is wrong but you never know
kids have such an intuition since he
said that I have these belly problems
and I'm beginning to ache all over it's
just incredible it's like black magic
you know when I wrote the book i
realized that i love chile i make fun of
it all the time I criticize it I
criticize how hypocritical we are our
prudishness I criticize how
superstitious we are our social class
system how much inequality and injustice
there is in the room in that country and
yet I love it and I love so many things
and I realized that more and more I feel
the same way about the United States and
that gives me that opened my heart and
my mind and I and I feel that as a
conclusion that I don't have to choose I
can have one foot there one foot here my
heart is not divided my heart just grew
bigger over there
just working on what you're saying now
Isabelle I'm very curious as now as your
books become more and more successful in
the United States and you're really
writing to to audiences you are writing
to the Latin audience who region the
original and you're writing more and
more to this other audience doesn't
there's so much they don't know and in
fact we as Latins see the United States
and no more much more about it than they
know about us and I just wonder how does
that affect you it's not just a question
translation but as you're writing and
thinking about your book books how are
you thinking about who your audience is
and do I have to explain it a little bit
more because they're going to translate
it into English and Americans won't know
what I'm talking about know that
affecting how you write no because my
books are translated to more than 30
languages and I can't control which
people in each country will be thinking
about it I just read a wonderful book
about Afghanistan by the way by it it's
out it's called The Kite Runner and and
I read the book and it was as if I had
been born there I didn't need any extra
explanation because really the emotions
the feelings the life that goes on in
different places is very similar
everywhere we may be more comfortable or
more safe in this country but we all
want the same things and I just don't
worry about who is going to read my
books and what how much people will
understand some people will understand
it in some level some people in another
level it's that's not my problem really
my problems to just tell the story
sometimes you know when I write I get
totally involved in my writing and I
spent the first few months of the year
locked away in a little Hut in the back
of my garden where I right that's the
time when my love my husband loves
because he doesn't see me only at seven
o'clock and sometimes I I finished the
day tired and I'm we sit at the table
and I say to Willie Willie I'm I will
never be able to write this book this is
just horrible this is not coming along I
just will never be able to write and he
says just tell the [ __ ] story
and that's the whole point tell the
story and tell the story and don't try
to preach don't try to change anybody
don't try to just tell the story and the
story has a way of bringing some truth
with it that reaches people and that's
why some books work and some books don't
work because there is a sort of thread
of truth that goes through all this pack
of lies that fiction is that touches the
hearts and the minds and that's what
works and it doesn't matter the language
or the subtleties or the changes in the
translation I don't think it matters in
my invented country you write some about
how the chilenos now love to forget and
I know down there at least in some
sectors people talk about how what was
once a cult of remembrance has become a
cult of forgetting especially in the
younger generation and my generation
yeah what amount of healing do you think
Chile has left to do and what role do
you think storytelling has to play in
that well Chile after the military coup
was divided the country was divided
families were divided and it for 17
years the country there were two nations
within the same territory the nation of
the those who supported the military and
lived in that system and the other ones
who where victims of the repression or
the ones that had to leave and then we
have had now 14 years of democratic
government and much of the of the
process of healing is done justice has
not been done because we know chair will
never be punished and many of the people
who were involved in violation of Human
Rights will never have to pay for their
crimes but I think that more and more
people understand that that is not
really the point the point is that the
truth be known because you know you
cannot start a process of reconciliation
on the basis of forgetting a bad memory
you only start reconciliation with the
truth and this happened in South Africa
and it has happened in many other places
when the truth emerges and we can face
it and we can talk about it then we can
honor the victims we can promise that it
will not happen again and we win we can
strengthen those institutions on those
values that will prevent it from
happening again and I think in that
sense it is important now there's a new
generation in Chile that was born during
the time of the dictatorship has grew up
in schools where the textbooks were
censored and changed and history was
changed and most of them are not
concerned with politics they don't
believe in the political systems and
this is a phenomenon that's happening
all over the world young people are not
very interested in politics because they
feel that the political institutions
were formed in the 19th century and they
don't no longer represent the the
problems of the 21st century and many
things need to be changed but but they
get involved in other ways and sooner or
later they will have to get involved
it's impossible to have the world run by
a generation that is not concerned with
the world so that will change yes ariel
dorfman in his book the title is
traveling south looking north or be
close he indicates that you and your
sister were vital in dissuading him from
proceeding to the mansion in the hours
after the 1973 cou could you briefly
tell us your recollections and your
feelings about that dramatic moment okay
I'm not the person that I real Dorfman
is referring to he's referring to
Isabella yendor the daughter of the
president and who the my recollections
are therefore very different so it's not
exactly what I real Dorfman is talking
about but if you want to know what my
recollections are that day the day of
the military coup I was in chile
santiago and i just took my car and went
to the to my office every day and then i
noticed i didn't have a radio in my car
but i noticed that the streets were
almost empty there was no public
transportation there were crowds of
people waiting for
public buses that didn't come and I saw
a lot of military convoys and airplanes
passing by military airplanes and and I
realized that something strange was
happening and we have been hearing a lot
about the possibility of a military coup
but no one in Chile really knew what
that was all about and I continued and I
reached the office and I saw it was
closed and a person who was there said
Lee bleep go back home because this is
the military coup there was a military
coup and and I want to look for a
telephone to call and see what had
happened with my kids that had left for
school and I stopped at the other
friends house and she said my husband
she was standing at the door and she
said my husband left very early because
he was a teacher and he had to correct
some exams and he had left like a five
o'clock in the morning that day and I
haven't heard from him so I said I'm
going to go to the school and pick him
up and this was 92 da national which is
in downtown Santiago and so from the
roof of the instituto nacional with
these teacher we saw the bombing of the
palace and and so that's the moment when
everything changed in Chile because you
know for Americans it's difficult to
understand this we had the most solid
democracy in the continent we had never
had a military coup we thought that that
would never happen in Chile the chili
was it was like England like a country
that was immune to this kind of thing
and in order for an American or British
person to understand what this the
feeling was you have to imagine that all
of a sudden the armed forces in the
United States take over and they bomb
the White House and they kill the
president in the process and they close
the Congress and they censor all the
media and for then then they arrest and
kill and torture and expelled from the
country any dissident voice and then
they remain in power for 17 long years
that is what happened in chile and so it
was such a
shocked that it is very it was very hard
to understand at the beginning because
first of all we all thought that it was
not going to last that it had been like
like a terrible accident and things
would go back to normal very soon I
think that the only people who wished
for the military to stay in power was
the extreme right because all the people
who supported the military at the
beginning very soon were horrified at
the idea of losing the democratic
institutions and the Christian Democrats
and others wanted elections and they
wanted to have the democratic system put
back in place nobody expected it to last
as long as it did and to have the brutal
characteristics that it had its you
thank you yeah buenas tardes and when I
that if I just want to first compliment
you on your your writing style I thank
you i love it i enjoy it i love it too
it's a pleasure greed and my question
deals more with the craft with your
writing style and with writing in
general i fancy myself as a storyteller
I enjoy writing but I find that my
motivation wayne's sometimes and I I
just would like to know from your
perspective how do you keep motivated to
continue telling stories is it is it a
catharsis is it something deeper is it
financial what my dear it's a job
you know i have taught writing in a few
places once in a while and I try to tell
my students that this has to be a
priority writing is not a hobby if you
want to be a writer this has to be the
main thing in your life you know when
you fall in love falling in love and
being with the other person is the
priority in your life and you postpone
everything else you you escape from the
office to make love behind the door well
that's what I writer does you right
behind the door because this is what you
really need to do and I do it in a
systematically and disciplined way I
have before I couldn't I had a day job
and for three books and at several years
I could not quit my day job because I
needed to support a family and very few
people can live just by writing books
unless your books are translated to many
languages and you're very successful
it's almost impossible you have to have
a day job so I kept my day job and I
wrote at night and I slept less and I
would skip lunch and every weekend and
every moment of my life was dedicating
to writing because that was what I
wanted to do so if that's what you want
to do i would say at least write one
good pay today and that is like three
drafts or four and if you have one good
page a day you have 365 pages by the end
of the year you have a book that you can
submit to harper collins
but you have to do it I mean people want
to write the Great American Novel but
they don't go through the trouble of
writing my husband is a lawyer he is
adorable but he's really arrogant and
he's a lawyer he retired and he decided
to write all really angry because you
know sometimes I'm in a cocktail party
and this dentist comes over and says
when I retire I will write a novel and I
said when I retire I will do root canal
really insulting it's very insulting so
this is what I have tried to tell my
husband that it's not a hobby that you
do once in a while because you're a
retired lawyer this is a job and now
he's finished the book and he's
confronting the difficulties of trying
to get the book published because it
needs work a lot of work you describe
you describe the events of 1973 in Chile
among other things as events the
Chilean's believed could never happen
there and therefore in addition to the
inherent shock of it there was sort of
that added dimension of shock and
disbelief obviously this country on
September 11th experience something that
we thought could never happen here being
intimately involved with 1973 and its
aftermath and was that your country and
so forth as you were do you believe that
gives you any court of particular
insights about the way that Americans
are coming to grips with what happened
on September 11 you know when I came to
this country many years ago I said to my
husband there is a danger here in this
society which i have seen in many other
countries and the United States doesn't
see it in itself because we think and I
say we because now I'm an American that
we are immune to this kind of thing but
there is a large number of ultra
nationalist right-wing population that
if they could take over this country
would be a totally different place and I
saw that from the very beginning I was
sort of scared and two events are linked
in my mind the military coup happened on
a Tuesday September 11th 1973 and years
later we had that coup was a terrorist
attack on a democracy sponsored by the
CIA the United States has a shameful
reputation of
having destroyed legitimately
democratically elected governments in
many parts in the world and having
replaced them by brutal dictatorships
that would never be tolerated in this
country my country suffered one of those
dictatorships and then years later we
had another event on a Tuesday September
11 at almost the same time of the day
the terrorist attack on this democracy
when I saw the the until on television
the World Trade Center collapsing and
panic and flames and smoke and all that
I had to think of what I had seen before
that day standing on the roof of the
Institute honest you're not looking at
the palace bombed by the airplanes
because the images were very similar and
I have I have gone through that before I
know how it feels the surprise the shark
the disbelief and then the crazy hope
that it will go away it doesn't go away
until we make it go away and so I think
that until we lose the things that we so
much cherish we don't appreciate them
enough it's like health until we are
sick we don't realize how wonderful it
is to be healthy we don't realize how
wonderful it is everything that we have
in this country until we begin to lose
it and I don't think that the fear of
losing on the fear of being attacked
should make us unaware or should make us
ready to forget that we have to defend
what we have and I mean other things
that are more important than safety I I
don't believe that the world is a safe
place and I don't believe that happiness
is that important I don't believe that
we have the right to search for
happiness there are other things much
more important much more relevant than
happiness give me a break
and so I am very involved in all this
because I'm very interested I've lived
sixty years and I look back and say wow
if you live long enough you see the
circles like closing and you see how
everything is related i'm connected and
everything has meaning it's wonderful to
be 60 I look good for my age no time
okay well let me tell you it takes a lot
of money and discipline I will take
three more questions and then I'll sign
the books yes uh well I was going to
make a comment but you just took the
words right out of my mouth with your
last one but I had two questions
actually i just finished portrait in
sepia and i wanted to know who if any
one person was the inspiration for the
character of poppy I mean Paula Hawaii
yeah Paulina velvia in the imported in
sepia and ordering fortune and order of
fortune is my agent she's just like my
agent is fat powerful greedy great lady
that's my agent tell me about sales she
recognizes herself totally in the
characters I'm not being indiscreet or
anything and the other thing I wanted to
ask was what you said before I hope I
don't seem impertinent here but that you
were kind of when you wrote for the
colony you said you wrote horrible
things about men and I just wanted to
ask you if your your feminist themes or
any other themes that matter have
mellowed or changed that's very kind so
graceful aged
thank you for the question thank you I
have not mellowed down I have even more
I'm even more passionate you know I've
always been a feminist and that doesn't
mean that I don't like men I like them
therefore I want to improve them I
haven't I haven't mellowed down with age
at all I have always been as passionate
as I am today and I I don't think that
that age will do much change in that
sense I realize now that I have the same
beliefs and ideas that I had when I was
young and I would give my life for the
same causes that I did then and I'm just
as passionate I would again fall in love
the way I felt in love with Willie I
fell in love with Lily before that was
long ago but I could still do the same
crazy things I mean there's nothing
different the only thing is that now you
can take the risk there's nothing to
lose it's great ok the next question
over here one more question this one on
this one thank you for speaking to us
tonight I just wanted to ask you when
you said that right now about happiness
that there's something more relevant or
something more important than happiness
that surprised me and I wanted to ask
you what you were referring to what is
more important than happiness well when
I was growing up happiness was
irrelevant my grandparents would have
been surprised to learn I mean horrified
to learn that people paid good money to
go to therapy to get over there and
happiness to pay for that would have
been unthinkable life was supposed to be
hard and difficult and you get over you
have to get over the obstacles and have
a life in spite of unhappiness and
difficulties and there were moments to
celebrate and those moments were
cherished and and we did celebrate them
a lot but it life was not about being
happy it was about honor about service
about community about being responsible
about leaving a legacy for your children
to be proud of that kind of stuff was
what I was I grew up on
and and that's the kind of stuff like
that still sort of guides my my life and
I was never pampered I the idea that you
can open a faucet and hot water comes
out what's wonderful I mean when when
you grow up with cold water it's
fantastic to have hard water but you can
live without it and so that's the point
with happiness I i think that i have i
have had a wonderful full life and in my
life there has been a lot of sorrow and
losses and abandonment and pain and
violence and grief and a lot of success
and love and passion and lust and
chocolate and good stuff and that's what
it is about but if you ask me do you
want to be happy no I'm not looking for
happiness I want to be our own a good
writer I want to be effective I want to
connect with people I want to change
things I want to serve to give that's
what I want to do but be happy what
stupid thing to be happy
I can't hear you what was your favorite
bucks right what was my favorite yes
what your favorite book to write my
favorite book to write I don't have well
that's you're the first person who asked
that question that way because people
ask what is your favorite book but they
don't say what is your favorite book to
write which it's quite a different
question and I always say that the most
important book that I have ever written
is paola because it saved my life at a
point when I really wanted to commit
suicide I was so depressed that I just
couldn't bear life because my daughter
had died and i wrote this memoir and it
saved my life and it brought me back to
my body and to be the person I am and it
was it was a cathodic book and an
important book but the most fun book to
ride was the first one the house of the
spirits because I didn't know what I was
doing I had that I didn't have the
slightest idea I was so innocent I
didn't know that there was a world out
there of literary critics of professors
of publishers of agents of contracts I
didn't know that I would be asked the
same question over and over again in
thousand times that I would be compared
to Gabriel Garcia Marquez that I didn't
know any of that I just wrote and I let
the story flow and I didn't know if it
was ever going to be published and I
didn't care much and nothing had
happened yet so everything that happened
with that book one step at a time
brought so much joy that I think that's
the most joyful experience of all also
it was a hard time in my life I was
going through a terrible marriage I had
a terrible job my kids were growing up
and they were going to the University
and I was losing my kids so and I felt
that I was getting old and I hadn't done
anything with my life so the joy of
finding a voice is something that that
is unique and I think that it only
happens with the first book
thank you so much thank you
isabel allende is author of the novels
portrait in sepia daughter of fortune
and the house of spirits her new memoir
my invented country is published by
Harper Collins on the web at
HarperCollins com next week on public
lives former news anchor Robert MacNeil
chronicles his personal